5 25 on mlk day monday here it is
freeway bridge demolition over eastern
round two hope you're not caught off
guard by the closure of eastern
underneath the 95 515 nevada department
of transportation demolishing another
part of the freeway bridge overhead it's
part of that 95 515 fix up project we've
been talking about so the on and off
ramps to and from eastern they are open
freeway traffic should be getting used
to those lanes that are shifting through
the area the closure of eastern
scheduled to last until next tuesday the
25th the recommended detour takes you on
either bonanza or stuart over to
maryland parkway for north south travel
local business access is still open on
eastern there's a lot more to come on
this project including more lane
restrictions another closure of di under
the freeway later this month but all of
this information including the links to
the n.i 515 project dot com website are
on eight news now dot com all i have to
do is click traffic then driving you
crazy buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone
something driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com